we present haptic revolvers a
reconfigurable VR controller that
enables touch sheer texture and shape
rendering on interactive surfaces
existing VR controllers only support
vibrotactile stimulation which is
limited in its ability to render
different textures and shapes what if as
you explored a virtual scene you could
feel the surfaces you touched our device
haptically renders the scene by making
contact with your finger when you touch
the surface and positioning arbitrary
haptic elements in virtual space
allowing you to feel what's beneath your
finger the haptic revolver consists of a
wheel that contains various haptic
elements a servo motor moves this wheel
up and down as you contact a virtual
surface a DC motor spins the wheel to
render shear forces and position haptic
elements under the fingertip the thumb
button on the side of the controller
enables input because our device is
tracked we can spatially register haptic
elements with the environment the motor
spins the haptic wheel to ensure
alignment between the features on the
wheel and the virtual scene through a
perceptual user evaluation we found that
we can adjust the wheel speed and
direction to manipulate the size of
virtual objects and even simulate motion
in multiple dimensions the haptic wheels
are interchangeable and can contain
different haptic elements such as shapes
textures or active electronic components
wheels can also be custom-designed for
different applications
for example here we show a card table
using a wheel with various textures and
edges when the user moves from one
surface to another our rendering engine
position is the wheel so that the
appropriate texture lies beneath the
finger and of the edge is felt in the
correct spot in this scene we show how
shapes on the wheel can add to the
realism of a virtual keyboard a user can
even brush along the rows of keys to
feel the grooves by sensing the force
the finger exerts on the wheel we turn
passive elements into interactive tools
here we show how a simple plastic nub
can be used as the tip of a scan of
spray paint for additional customization
electronic components such as buttons
and joysticks can be placed on the wheel
and is seen when the user approaches a
virtual interactive widget the rendering
engine places an appropriate physical
widget under the fingertip here we show
how the user can physically interact
with virtual knobs buttons and switches
you